le prochain sujet est gênant pour un
pays développés comme le canada
on croit qu'il y a environ 1200 femmes
autochtones qui ont disparu ou ont été
carrément assassiné au canada en trente
ans un drame dont les gouvernements
provinciaux et fédéral ne se coupe pas
suffisamment ce sont en tout cas les
conclusions du rapporteur spécial de
l'onu sur le droit des autochtones
reportage margot pas plus tard que ce
matin
nouveau rappel d'une tragédie trop
souvent oublié les plus récents données
de la grc font état de 1200 femmes
autochtones disparues ou assassinées
depuis 30 ans mais pour une huitième
fois une enquête publique est réclamée
au moment même où les projecteurs
viennent de l'extérieur les nations
unies utilise le terme crise pour
décrire la situation des premières
nations au canada
comment c'est monsieur rapport par
écouter la demande pour tenir une
enquête sur les pentes autochtones
disparues et au canada tel est le
constat du rapporteur spécial des
nations unies portent sur l'ensemble des
conditions des premières nations
son rapport fait suite à une visite
d'une semaine dans six provinces
canadiennes en octobre dernier
il note que l'écart entre le niveau de
vie des autochtones et du reste de la
population est toujours aussi grand
alors que dix ans plus tôt l'onu
recommandait justement d'agir pour
combler ce fossé yapo vraiment eu
d'amélioration depuis 2004 et bine pire
c'est qu'il ya certaines situations qui
sont sont devenus pire finalement santé
éducation logement les conditions
socio-économiques sont donc loin de
s'améliorer et les chefs doute de la
sincérité du gouvernement pour nous
la méfiance est très manifeste à
l'échelle du pays on le voit et on
l'entend dans toutes les correspondances
qu'on reçoit d'à peu près toutes les
régions à l'échelle du pays devant les
questions de l'opposition le
gouvernement lui se défend de ne rien
faire
au contraire le rapport des nations
unies conclut que les filles et les
femmes autochtones sont vulnérables et
recommande justement une enquête
nationale sur celles disparues ou
assassinées
mais ceux et celles qui étaient venus se
faire entendre
repartent encore plus frustré la
position du gouvernement ne change pas
et si marc godbout radio canada ottawa